I want a divorce are you drunk I've been
working on it for about four years and
we're really excited and I'm very very
happy to be home yes Sarah Jessica
Parker is coming home to HBO with her
new series divorce 39 years in the
business what makes you look at
something like divorce and say I want to
do that because you've done everything
what makes you excited to move it baby
develops i'll show it was an area of
particular interest to me because I'm
married and because I love being married
and you're happily married and I'm
happily married and and I think marriage
is wonderfully complicated and really
interesting and everybody conducts their
marriage differently it ended because it
needed to end right so what does divorce
look like and how painful it can be how
enormously energizing it can be how to
parties can't we want the same thing or
don't want the same thing how that what
is the portrait of a divorce and what is
the portrait of a marriage and I think
you know we're at an age where a lot of
people have experienced it or about to
or want to or secretly wish they could
or so grateful that their marriage isn't
at that state and so I love the idea of
telling that story